oui ce reportage nous rappelle beaucoup
cette maxime que vous connaissez presque
tous maintenant qui datent du 19e et
encore du début du xxème siècle il est
interdit de cracher par terre et de
parler breton cette phrase en effet
beaucoup de lecteurs l'ont découverte il
y a cinq ans à peu près grâce à pierre
jakez hélias et à ce livre
le cheval d'orgueil et bien pour ceux
qui n'ont pas encore lu ce livre qui est
une sorte de bible ici encore qu'il est
été contestés on se souvient du cheval
coucher de dévier graal tout chabrol
s'est proposé de tourner et de restituer
donc au cinéma ce que vous allez voir
dans à peu près trois mois la rentrée le
cheval d'orgueil tournée en pays
bigouden non pas ici à tréguier dans
cette superbe cathédrale au milieu du
pays du trégor mais en pays bigouden
c'est à dire pas très loin de quimper et
c'est là que les reporters de faire
trois sont allés rejoindre il y a
quelques jours tout chabrol tournant le
cheval d'orgueil
ce qui a été possible et là c'est de
voir un village entier comme je
l'espérais au village entier qui
correspond à ce qu'il était en 1900 et
en 1910 évidemment cce tant mieux
d'ailleurs c'est un fait je m'affale
fille alors ce qu'on a fait on a en a
pris plusieurs plusieurs coins
différents et il y aura un village
fictif dont on a fait d'ailleurs le la
topographie mais qui n'existe pas qui
sera de la cu l'assemblage de plusieurs
plusieurs endroits différents
la moitié des gens qui joueront le fus
sont des comédiens professionnels je ne
suis pas utiliser les amateurs mais ces
comédiens professionnels j'essayais une
ou deux exceptions près de ne pas les
prendre trop célèbre pour pour que le
décalage de leur célébrité vérone qu'ils
ont interprété avant ne crée pas un
problème pour les notifications avec le
refus de m
elle s'est donnée dans toute la force
vient de la vérité des détails donc il
suffit pour moi de respecter cette
vérité pour en tout cas avoir là une
grosse partie de du livre soul et on
peut dire en gros qu'il va du début du
siècle à un modèle au début de la guerre
de 40 noeuds deuxième bien mondiale nous
nous arrêtons la fin de la première il
ya eu là un moment de transformation
très importante parce que le bigouden
qui était très fermé sur lui même
cet aperçu d'un seul coup qu il
appartenait à une une collectivité qui
était calé jusqu'au rhin quoi et pour la
can est obligé de donner son sang est en
même temps les gens de
il fallait que la vie continue et ce
sont les femmes qui sont mis à s'occuper
des c'est très très bien nous garde
absolument aucun droit je viens voir le
tournage du film est naturellement je
suis là pour tous les renseignements
qu'il est possible de demander mais ceci
dit moi je laisse les artistes faire
exactement ce qui leur plaît ce qu'ils
ont dans la tête
d'autre part je n'ai absolument aucun
goût pour la censure